[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
Bible related question give us a call
now at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
English diecasters Leslie Smith and
Rodney Smith founded lesney products in
1947 and along with her partner Jack
Odell they began making small toys
in 1952 Odell was challenged by a rule
at his daughter's school
the rule permitted students to only
bring toys to school that were small
enough to fit inside a matchbox
so he scaled down Lindsay's little
Steamroller package and put it in a
matchbox and sent his daughter off to
school
the Matchbox car was born
since 1953 Matchbox cars have sold
around the world
the first little car sold for 39 to 48
cents and came in a small matchbox-like
container the toys are made by measuring
real full-size cars or trucks with a
laser and then reducing the dimensions
to be about 1 64th the size of the
original model
to date there have been more than twelve
thousand individual Matchbox models with
a total production of over 3 billion
miniature toy cars and trucks
you know the Bible speaks of three
structures that were made as Miniatures
of heavenly copies
that's right Pastor Doug when you think
about the Matchbox car I think just
about every little boy at some point in
time has seen one or played one or I
know and you've got a few boys that they
have they sure did we still got a bucket
I think of Matchbox cars in the attic
and I think what's so appealing is that
they look just like the real thing but
of course miniature I've been shrunk
that's right it's kind of neat to look
at it and say wow this is what the real
thing looks like well you know the Bible
talks about a miniature structure that
was recreated here on the earth that's
right the Bible tells us that when Moses
went up Mount Sinai not only did he get
the Ten Commandments but he received a
lot of the the laws both civil health
and religious while he was on the
mountains and God gave him plan specific
plans the same way Noah was given
specific plans for the ark God gave
Moses specific plans to build a
tabernacle a sanctuary that was a
miniature model
of a Heavenly Sanctuary that you read
about several places in the Bible
and one example would be you can look in
Hebrews chapter 8 verse 4 it says for if
he were on Earth he would not be a
priest since there are priests who offer
gifts according to the law who serve the
copy and Shadow of the Heavenly things
as Moses was divinely instructed when he
was about to make the Tabernacle that's
the sanctuary for he said see that you
make all things according to the pattern
shown you on the mountain
like we know the Ark of the Covenant was
the golden box of the Ten Commandments
on on the top they were two Golden
Angels well in heaven God doesn't sit
enthroned between two golden statues of
angels he sits between living angels
just like a little Matchbox car while
the doors don't open I mean it's it's a
little model but the very real Temple in
heaven instead of having a wallpaper
with angels like the earthway sanctuary
it's probably a living wall of angels
that surrounds the Lord
and I said three because there are three
times it was built you've got the mobile
Tabernacle in the wilderness
then Solomon ultimately built at David's
instruction and David provided for it
one of the wonders of the world the the
Temple of Solomon
and that was then destroyed by
Nebuchadnezzar and after the Babylonian
captivity it was rebuilt during the
times of Ezra and Nehemiah later
refurbished by Herod the Great but it
was basically the same Temple and so
these are all Miniatures of the Heavenly
model and that Temple teaches us Pastor
Ross something about how God Saves
people that's right the Bible says thy
way O Lord he's in the sanctuary so
looking at the services of the sanctuary
of course you've got the sacrifices that
took place in the sanctuary you've got
the priesthood and the work that the
priests did and all of the Articles of
furniture they all teach a lesson that
points us to The Plan of Redemption and
Jesus our sacrifice and also great high
priest and also living the Christian
Life that's also present in the
sanctuary so we do have a study guide
that talks about the sanction it's
called God drew the plans and this is
our free gift we're going to send it out
to anyone who calls and asks the number
for that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for off number
one two nine or ask for it by name it's
called God drew the plans you can also
dial pound 250 on your phone and say
Bible answers live and then ask for God
drew the plans you can also receive the
free gift that way and I would like to
greet those who are listening on some
radio stations that we have across the
country we want to greet those tuning in
on kwrg in Arizona those who are
listening there welcome and also kpgc in
Arkansas so if you have a Bible question
you're listening through these two one
of these two radio stations we'd love to
hear from you tonight and for anyone who
has a Bible question the number to call
is 800-463-7297
that's 800 God says 800
463-7297 and that'll bring you here into
our program we also want to greet those
who are watching on YouTube and Facebook
also on AF TV and some other networks
that are going to be rebroadcasting this
program we thank you for being a part of
our Bible study I'll pass it out before
we go to the phone lines I know there's
quite a few callers waiting let's start
with prayer amen dear father we thank
you once again that we do have this time
to open up your word and study the Bible
is the most important book A book that
you have given us to show us the way of
Truth the Bible says that Thy word is a
lamp to our feet so guide us Lord as we
study together in Jesus name amen amen
well our first caller this evening is
Brittany and she's listening in
California Brittany welcome to Bible
answers live
hey
hi
yeah my question is why do bad things
happen to good people and there are the
past week's events part of the sign of
the times
yeah that is a great question and yeah
you know and I for those who are
listening sometimes these programs are
are rebroadcast and uh last week at the
time of this recording there was another
school shooting and some kids were
killed and and a lot of people just have
very uh serious questions I think
there's so much evil in the world with
innocent people suffering at the hands
of wicked and why does God allow this if
he's a loving God if he's all powerful
why doesn't he just stop it if there's a
devil why would God make a devil if he's
a good loving God and people have a lot
of questions first I'd recommend
that anyone who has those questions if
you have not seen the cosmic conflict
DVD of course it's on YouTube just type
in Cosmic conflict and you will see a
DVD that was produced that explains
where did Evil come from why does God
not just destroy the Devil is yet he
will the Bible tells us
um and and why are there innocent people
suffering here in this world not just in
these school shootings and other
senseless things we see happening around
the world the war in Ukraine and so
forth
um
but you read in the Book of Job where
job was a good just upright righteous
man and just all these terrible things
happened the Book of Job sort of gives
you a picture behind the scenes that the
the bad things that happened to job
came from the Devil
and uh there's the devil has hijacked
this world because our first parents
were made free and God said don't
disobey and eat this forbidden fruit and
the devil said listen to me don't listen
to God and when Adam and Eve chose to
listen to the devil they really kind of
handed over the keys of our world they
surrendered Dominion of this world to
the enemy Paul says in Romans chapter 6
that whoever you obey that's whose
servants you are and they basically gave
the world to the devil even Jesus refers
to the devil as the prince of this world
so that's why there's so much suffering
we ought to be asking the question since
the penalty for sin is death why aren't
we all dead
it's the goodness of God that protects
us and is giving us some probationary
time to make another decision to choose
Jesus and choose forgiveness
good question and we I think we've got a
lesson on did God make a devil we do but
we also have a book that might be a
little more directed to your question
it's called The Brook dried up why do
Christians suffer and that's free we'll
send it to anyone here in the US and in
Canada the number to call is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
book The Brook dried up and we'll be
happy to send it to you if you're
listening outside of North America we
want to encourage you go to our website
just
amazingfacts.org click on our free
library and you'll be able to read the
book right there online it's called The
Brook dried up thank you for your call
Brittany we've got Jerry listening in
Texas Jerry welcome to the program
Jerry in Texas you're on the air
sometimes our listeners are muted while
they're waiting they don't realize it
Jerry we don't hear you if you're on one
more time Jerry Texas
you there all right we might have to
come back to Jerry Gary in Illinois Gary
welcome to the program
thank you in Revelation 16 9 it says
that manner scorched with a great heat
and they did not repent well this could
be you know solar players so my question
is are natural disasters and the Bulls
of the wrath of God one and the same and
that's why people uh aren't repenting uh
when these uh these uh you know horrific
extraordinary natural disasters happen
yeah well uh through history not
connected with the seven last plagues
but through history I think that God has
sometimes allowed natural disasters as a
judgment
but not every natural disasters from the
Lord you read in the Book of Job we just
reference
the Bible says the devil went forth from
the presence of the Lord and he brought
a tornado that killed the children of
job the house blew down and we had
tornadoes this last week doesn't mean
God sent them
sometimes the devil can even influence
nature he was the most powerful of God's
creation and he's got a lot of power
even over the weather but then the seven
plagues many of them appear to be
nature reacting somehow many of the
seven plagues are sort of similar to the
plagues that fell in ancient Egypt
namely the blood the sores and the the
darkness on the seat of the Beast the
the people being scorched with great
Heat
you know it may also be connected with
something happening in the atmosphere or
solar flares but um
yeah I mean God often uses natural
things to
um do a judgment for example in the case
of Egypt when the plagues came they were
literal locusts that infested that the
land so God can use the Sun but it's
clearly an act of judgment that comes uh
why do the people not repent during the
Civilized Place well at that point the
Holy Spirit has been withdrawn from
those who have rebelled against God
probation is closed and we go through
what we call the great time of trouble
that you read about in Daniel chapter 12
verse 1 so people's minds are pretty
much made up at that point and instead
of these plagues bringing them to a
point of repentance the Bible says they
they Curse God they blame God they
blaspheme his name for sending the place
so they know where it's coming from but
their hearts are hard and they've set in
doing evil and the plagues reveal that
we're going to try Jerry one more time
Jerry in Texas are you there
I'm there guys finally hey thanks Pastor
for saying uh taking my call yeah I have
several Bible texts in reference to the
question I'm asking and uh it's halfway
you know you have to get spiritual
knowledge to do that what is the true
physical nature of his physical nature
we have in Genesis Angels held swords
and uh we have Paul in Acts uh 19 15 and
16 that the men that were wanting to get
the Holy Spirit the angels to pound it
on you know beat them up or so and then
we have Roger moray's dog was kicked by
Angel and then in Ezekiel I guess we
have that Satan will have fire rep from
his abdomen and he has wings I guess he
did have a crown
yeah so
um it seems sometimes you know one place
it says that the angels and Pastor Ross
this is I think they're his mirror it
says their uh Spirits we don't wrestle
against flesh and blood that's Ephesians
6 but also in Hebrews when it talks
about the Angels there ministering
spirits that are sent forth to minister
for those who will inherit eternal life
Hebrews 114. thank you that's the one so
we've got several verses that tell us
that angels are spirits
but at the same time we see them
interacting in a physical way with our
world on many occasions where they are
moving things and doing things both good
and bad Angels typically the devil when
he interacts with the environment he
does it through a creature or a person
that's possessed I mean even the demons
cast out of a man they said put us in
the pigs you know do something like that
and Satan he operated through the medium
of a serpent but they they are able to
somehow interact with our dimension
and so they are very real creatures I
think the confusion comes in that we
don't understand
what the spiritual realm is we assume
that when something spiritual that means
that it has no substance
the way we understand it but there's a
whole dimension that in which Angels
Live and operate and I would just say to
everyone listening the Miracle by which
you're listening now or watching on
television
we didn't know about a hundred years ago
we didn't know about radio waves and
those frequencies and gamma rays and
x-rays and and there's a whole world
that we can't see we Now understand
well I don't think we've yet figured out
uh the equipment to diagnose and measure
the spiritual realm but it's very real
and so Angels somehow are able to
interact with our Physical World when
they choose to reveal themselves
uh Bible says Satan can appear as an
angel of Light and they can do Miracles
and they can move things so it is
something of a mystery
all right well thank you for your call
Jerry we've got Johnny listening in
Kentucky Johnny welcome to the program
hello thank you
um I was wondering do you have any
advice on how to witness to family
members who are running away from God
and spend nearly all their time on
violent video games violent movies and
violent media in general
hmm well you know there's three things
you can do for the people you love and I
know it's heartbreaking when you see
people you care about and you love they
don't seem to be interested in
eternity in the Holy Spirit and serving
God but there's really only three I I
say three and it's technically four
things that you do
that you when you want to reach somebody
the one is you be a good witness let
your light shine
the other would be pray for them
God does things when you pray that would
not happen otherwise prayer really does
make a difference
uh the other is if they're open share
information so if you've got friends and
they're preoccupied with watching media
and it's not good say hey I've got this
video it's called Cosmic conflict now or
I've got this video called The Bride the
beast in Babylon these are a couple done
by amazing facts so you really would
enjoy this and just if they're open but
sometimes you can't you know your
friends won't listen they won't read
material they won't watch something you
give them
so the fourth thing is you do the first
three
persistently don't give up pray for them
be a good witness and share information
when they're available don't nag them I
don't Badger them with information
because you can drive them away
uh you don't want to do that but keep
praying their hearts will be open and
study with them if they're open
absolutely and of course that's
something we need to do we need to be
the best witness that we can for our
family and our friends and we need to
pray that God gives us wisdom to know
when to speak or when to be quiet so
that's something that we need to be
connected to God with we've got Carly
listening in um is it Nebraska Carly
welcome to the program
well thank you very much and thank both
of you for having this program and being
there I have a verse Colossians 1 24
that I have never really understood and
today in my daily reading I've come
across something that is a
a brand new
thought at China bothers me when I read
it and I wanted to run it by you
well let me read the verse for our
friends that are listening I'll read
Colossians 1 24 is that right
yes and I understand that Paul is not
speaking of Christ's suffering here that
he's explaining to the people his own
sufferings let me read it real quick for
those listening I now rejoice in my
sufferings for you and fill up my flesh
and what is lacking in the afflictions
of Christ for the sake of his body which
is the church
okay
well I never quite understood the
lacking part and I
what I read was
like I say a brand new thought that
there's been several explanations but it
could be possibly that this text
indicates Christ's afflictions did not
end after his Ascension and I'm reading
this now and that consequently he
continues to identify himself with the
church that as in the Believers fulfill
the mission of the church Christ is now
being afflicted by the afflictions of
Believers suggesting that he is somehow
experiencing them and himself and he
says this will come to an end at his
return in glory and I thought Christ
isn't
conflicted anymore and I thought that
he's
being affected
yeah well let's talk about that that's
an interesting observation uh you know
it tells us in the Bible that Jesus is
not physically you know he's in heaven
now at the right hand of the father he's
not physically suffering uh on the cross
anymore he was crucified once
Jesus does feel everything and so he
said in as much as you've done it to the
least of these you've done it to me so
whether we do something kind or whether
someone does something evil to another
person Christ feels the pain in that you
know he empathizes with the pain of his
creatures so in that sense he suffers
Paul is probably not referring to that
here when he talks about the afflictions
of Christ I think he's talking about
where Peter said that you know don't be
shocked if we share in his sufferings
but if we do rejoice and Paul probably
more than any Apostle
he did go through a lot of hardship and
sufferings he was beaten and stoned and
imprisoned and so he said look you know
I killed Christians and the Lord is
letting me taste some of those
sufferings now
what do you think yeah I think so you
know he said my strength is made perfect
in weakness and um Paul was an example
of faithfulness even despite terrible
suffering and then of course you read
about Paul's list and you mentioned some
of them another one was Shipwrecked yeah
imprisoned eventually he was beheaded
for his faith so you know Christians can
look at that and say he had so many
things happen to him and yet look how
positive and convinced he was of the
love of God look at how strong his faith
was so he's an example and you know Paul
is acknowledging that my Affliction is
probably not over there's probably more
that's going to come
that's right and when he said fill up
the measure of suffering he meant
sometimes God has to let us suffer to
learn things and Paul said I'm still
learning so God's going to fill it up
all right hey thanks so much I hope that
helps Carly we've got Anna listening in
Oregon Anna welcome to the program
hi thank you for taking my question
again guys thank you
um
so my question is you probably get it
all the time but um the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit and sometimes I
think I get it and then
I don't and then I do and then I don't I
would like you to explain it to me yeah
well
it'll it'll be hard in three minutes to
explain God uh you know the Bible says
his ways are higher than our ways that
then the stars are above the Earth
and job said God is past finding out so
you know if we ever got where we could
wrap our brains about around God someone
who has lived from Everlasting to
Everlasting have made the cosmos you
know it's quite literally a mind-blowing
thought but there is information
revealed about the the functions for
lack of a better word of the father son
and spirit are different I heard you
explain it once Pastor Ross in kind of
three phases you know what I'm talking
about
they've got to remind me okay well you
know the father's the father's the
authority and Jesus is the medium that
he reveals the father he's the one who
saves us and the Holy Spirit who is he's
going and doing the bidding of the
father and the son and leading the
teaching the convicting The Guiding and
there's verses that support these things
you know Jesus even said God the father
created all things through the son so
God the Father seems to they there's a a
willing submission of the Son and the
spirit to the father
because the father is the one who so
loves the world he sends his son and
then you've got the the father it tells
us he commits judgment to the son he
commits creation to the son
the spirit you see of course right there
at creation is there in every facet of
creation and salvation
and is he's sort of the constantly the
one communing between the father and the
son and the spirit
anyway we we do have a book that is
called
um uh understanding the Trinity and
we'll be happy to send you a copy of
that uh Debbie is that Debbie asking no
that's Anna I'm sorry and hopefully
that'll help a little bit then I'm going
to call for that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
The Trinity is it biblical we'll be
happy to send it to you
next quality I have is Debbie excuse me
listening in Canada Debbie welcome to
the program
Hi how are you good thanks for calling
okay first of all I want to say Pastor
Doug I still have your richest caveman
book with your signature in it I
remember fighting over not fighting but
push my way through a crowd to get you
to sign it unbelievable book changed my
whole life praise the Lord
yep okay now the question I have is it's
not really is I I would think it would
be a Biblical I'm trying to keep my body
clean well not drying I am but when I
die I just filled out my um health card
and they ask you a question on the
health card
Protege thing is do you want to be an
organ donor yeah you want to donate your
organs and I said yes is that against
Bible principle
well it's a great question I had to ask
myself the same question my driver's
license also says yes
just because I know I'm getting a new
body
and if you know if there's any of my
parts that are of any use in the older
you get less likely that is but uh you
know if
um if there's some part that is going to
give someone else sight you know we lost
the sun about 20 years ago and they
asked us they said you know would you be
willing to donate his cornea that could
be translated in someone else to help
them see and we said absolutely because
otherwise it just you know it's going to
turn back into ashes the Bible tells us
and so and we feel the same way now I
don't think that I I don't support
cremation
because it's just basically you know
burning up your body but
um you know if if there were some parts
that could help another person have life
Jesus is all about sacrifice for others
all right thank you Debbie we've got uh
let's see Glenn in Ohio Glenn welcome to
the program
Glenn you're on the air might be muted
Glenn
Glenn in has a question about Zechariah
are you there
'll win once okay all right we're gonna
jump to James in uh Texas James welcome
to the program
James you're on the air yes sir yes can
you hear me yes
yes sir um my question is uh I'm I
intend to be I'm a re-baptized on Easter
Sunday oh wow but it is but is there
gonna be a is there a special order for
my repentance like um is there baptism
confession repentance or
or any kind of special order I have to
end up doing yeah well you'll read in
Acts chapter 2 when the people said to
Peter uh after Peter preaches his sermon
and I forget it's like verse 38 maybe
they said men and Brethren what shall we
do Peter said repent and be baptized and
John the Baptist he said repent and be
baptized so repentance is a sorrow for
sin and a willingness to turn away from
sin
it's a U-turn where you turn from your
old ways and you would walk in a newness
of life that should definitely come
before baptism so it's like if baptism
is like marriage and if you're going to
marry a particular girl she's going to
say I want to make sure you're done
dating all the other girls before we get
married you don't say well after we get
married then I'll I'll try and stop
dating the other girls so you you want
to it doesn't mean you need to be
perfect before you're baptized but you
should you know Express sorrow for your
sins confess your sins that God repent
from your sins
and then when you are baptized you have
followed the criteria you then come from
the water and all your sins are forgiven
and God says he cleanses you from all
unrighteousness when we confess our sins
hey friends you can tell we're going to
take a break don't go too far because
we've got a lot more Bible questions
coming and I think we've got a special
offer we can make available to
um Glenn when we come back got
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
thank you
hi friends Pastor Doug Batchelor it's
time to make your plans and mark your
calendars to attend our third annual
amazing facts youth conference the dates
are June 7th through the 10th 2023. this
year's Mission and title is called
identity change by beholding come and
learn how to turn your focus from the
world to the word and make some great
friends along the way for more
information about the speakers and how
you can register go to afyouth.com Doug
Batchelor was the teenage son of a
millionaire father and show business
mother yet he was living in a cave he
had everything money could buy
everything but happiness but all of the
fun and excitement he enjoyed left his
life out of control his search
eventually led him to a cave above Palm
Springs that became his home while Doug
scavenged for food and garbage bins his
father owned a yacht a Learjet and an
airline but in his cave home he
discovered a dust-covered Bible
as he began to read he soon learned of
his true purpose in life
the richest caveman is the extraordinary
true story of Doug Batchelor that tells
how a rebellious teenager who once lived
in a cave became a tremendous Soul
winner for Jesus Christ it's a thrilling
testimony of the transforming power of
God's word to order your copy of the
richest caveman call
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
in six days God created the heavens and
the Earth
for thousands of years man has worshiped
God on the seventh day of the week now
each week millions of people worship on
the first day what happened why did God
create a day of rest does it really
matter what day we worship who is behind
this great shift discover the truth
behind God's law and how it was changed
visit sabbathtruth.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian Life call us now
at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and we've been doing this
program for over 27 years now if you've
got a Bible question then you just can
give us a phone call and uh 800 God Says
with your Bible question and we'll do
our best to answer it we've got some
Bible resources at the tips of our
fingers here we're streaming now on
Facebook that's the amazing facts
Facebook page the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page and YouTube The Amazing
Facts YouTube page we're on AF TV and a
number of other stations radio and
television my name is Doug Batchelor my
name is John Ross and we got uh Julie
listening in Pennsylvania is it Julie
welcome to the program
hi there how are you good thank you for
calling
all right
um so I had a question for you I I
basically wanted to know about
what the symbolism was with Ezekiel and
the wheel what was that encounter like
yeah you not only find the wheel within
the wheel here in Ezekiel chapter 10.
it's also mentioned in chapter one and
you can read in Ezekiel 1 it says now as
I looked at the and this is Ezekiel 115
now as I looked at the living creatures
Behold a wheel was on the earth beside
each living creature with its four faces
and the appearance of the wheels and
their workings was like the color of
burl and all four had the same likeness
and he says that you go on it says the
appearance of their workings was as it
was a wheel in the middle of a wheel and
when they moved they went towards any of
the four directions and they did not
turn aside as they went for their rims
they had so high and they were awesome
and then it says the rims are full of
eyes all around and I've had people say
well this is Ezekiel saw a UFO or he saw
an alien uh and uh folks have all
wondered what is this it looks a wheel
within a wheel it's like a watch where
the gears inside or is it some kind of a
caterpillar where you've got the tracks
turning the wheel within a wheel and I
just people have been all over the map
with this but Pastor Ross as far as I
know Ezekiel is having an apocalyptic
Vision here and so there's symbolism
and the idea of a wheel within a wheel
is telling us that you know God is
really in charge of all time and the
idea that there's eyes all around it
means he has his interactions
that are helping make every little
Providence happen and that God is
completely in control the the purpose of
ezekiel's vision he's trying to wonder
why why have these terrible things
happen to the nation of Israel they are
conquered and carried off and by the
Babylonians and then the Persians and
God is saying you know I'm working out
my perfect plan and to you it may look
like a wheel within a wheel but there
everywhere those wheels go there's a
direction and a purpose so it is a
mystery and if you look at the throne
room described in Revelation chapter
four talks about the four living
creatures and it says there are six
wings and they have eyes so the symbol
of eyes being all-knowing God is aware
of everything and then the wheels the
Throne of God appears to move yeah so
there are some parallels I think uh in
describing God's Throne as you see it in
Revelation but also the symbolic
application of that yeah absolutely and
the four creatures are very similar in
Ezekiel to the ones you see if not
identical to the ones you see in
Revelation
so I hope that helps a little bit uh
Glenn we we sure are sorry that was Huli
we sure appreciate your question
next goal that we have we're going to
try Glenn one more time I think um Glenn
are you there in Ohio Glen welcome to
the program
yes thank you very much for taking my
call I hope we made it through this time
you did you're on
good and my my Bible studies I was
studying in a wonderful book in
Zechariah the eighth chapter and I got
to verse 19. and it talks about the four
fasts of four months the fourth month
fifth month seventh month and tenth
month I I'm concerned what that fast is
about and what calendar is is they
talking about can you help me
yeah I think he's referring back to the
the feast that you would find in
Leviticus
uh where you've got the what was it
seven annual feasts and some of them
involve fasts there were days of fasting
and um so this would be what they called
the spiritual calendar
that began with the Passover now Israel
had both a civil calendar that was a
little bit different from their their
religious or spiritual calendar
and in the Jewish spiritual calendar
they had their fall festivals and then
they had their spring festivals and then
there was the day of atonement which was
the last festival at the end of the
spiritual year and I know there was a
fast at the beginning of Passover and
there was also a feast with Passover so
they had both and I'm pretty sure that
Zechariah is also talking about those
fasts that you find there now we do have
a book we can share that talks about
Jesus in the feast days
and uh I I looked on our new lineup of
books and we do have a book that talks
about the feast days yeah so if if Glenn
wants to call I'm sorry is that uh Glenn
is that right yeah he wants to call and
ask for that we'll be happy to share
that the number to call for that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book on
Jesus and the feast days and we'll send
that to anyone here in the U.S or in
Canada next holiday that we have is Thai
and he's listening in Minnesota Tai
welcome to the program
tie you on here hi
and your question
okay good question
why doesn't God just destroy Satan well
you know when uh when children sometimes
disobey their parents
parents are very loving and patient they
want their children to understand and
Obey them because they love them because
what they're asking is good and
reasonable
um
that's the reason that God did not
destroy the Devil right away is he did
not want the other Angels obeying
because they were afraid they were going
to get killed if they didn't disobey God
doesn't want us motivated just by fear
of punishment God wants us to obey him
because we love him and the devil was
accusing God of some terrible thing so
God had to allow Satan to demonstrate to
the world what was going to happen he's
showing the World by his patients that
following the devil leads to all kinds
of pain people had to find out and see
what was going to happen
so you would enjoy tell your parents to
help you watch The Cosmic conflict DVD
it's free you can watch it online just
go to YouTube and type in Cosmic
conflict it's the one with uh Pastor
Doug and you'll see it there thanks so
much Ty next quarter that we have is
Terry listening in Tennessee Terry
welcome to the program
thank you uh Pastor Ross hi uh Pastor
Doug how are you guys all right we're
doing great thank you for calling
no thank you
and your question hello yeah you're
there yeah yeah
um
um it's not so much on the scriptures
but I just kind of wondered um
when um
the Exiles that were put in Babylon
um with when Jeremiah was a prophet they
stayed there 70 years and then they
returned okay
why didn't they set up their Kingdom
like it was before they before they
exiled with their own King and
everything from the House of David right
right good question there yeah they
would love to have done that but when
they were allowed to go back from
Babylon to Israel they did it under the
um the rulership of the King of Persia
in other words all they could do was
have a governor and so the King of
Prussia said you don't have a king
anymore I am the king
um and you will pay tribute to me but
I'm going to give you your freedom and
you'll have your own governor and from
the time of the Babylonian captivity now
there may have been a brief period where
they broke away from the Greeks during
the time of The Maccabees but other than
that they were under the the Persians
then they were under the Greeks and then
they were under the Romans and then the
Romans destroyed the city they never had
a monarchy again
but when Jesus comes he is the son of
David that will reign over the New
Jerusalem so all the promises about
Israel and God's people inhabiting the
world will be fulfilled in the son of
David Christ when he establishes his
kingdom
thanks so much I hope that helps a
little bit all right we've got Terry
listening in Virginia Terry welcome to
the program another Terry
welcome uh
uh yes hi thank you for taking my call
yes and your question
is the First Corinthians chapter 11 1 to
16.
polish opinion or is it a message from
God and how should we understand it
please all right well you you quoted a
lot of verses but I think you're talking
about where it talks about women
covering their heads when they pray and
that's the section if I'm not mistaken
right
right yeah so the big question
um that people have here is was this a
custom or was this a commandment for
every people on every age that women
should not pray in public without having
their hints covered
and most of the commentaries believe
that Paul is addressing a custom of
respect
during his time there's no command in
the Old Testament we can find where it
says a woman must cover her head when
she prays or when she's in worship
you do have examples of women that were
praying in public it doesn't tell us
what they might have had on their head
I'd say first of all if a person feels
convicted about this well by all means
do it you know if you go to Russia
still a lot of the Orthodox Churches of
women always cover their heads when they
pray and and I've worshiped in
Pentecostal churches years ago when
whenever they prayed they covered their
heads if a woman was praying in public
and but Paul mentions later in the verse
and I'm trying to remember where it was
he said yeah verse 16 he says if anyone
seems to be contentious we have no such
custom nor do the Churches of God
so he's using the word custom there and
it makes us think they're talking about
a custom of respect
this is the only place this is mentioned
um
so you know I don't know that they had
these Apostle Taliban that were telling
all the women that they had to cover
their heads and get thrown out of the
church but there was a customer and they
were having problems in Corinth some
have said that you know the um
the immoral women in the cities they
used to braid their hair with chains of
gold and leave it uncovered and so to
show that you are a believer that you
would cover your hair which was your
glory as a sign of submission to God and
even your husband
so this this is the understanding I've
seen from those verses
all right I think the point there is
showing respect and reverence yeah and
of course that's applicable not only to
women also to men in our culture if a
man enters into a church and he's
wearing a hat the appropriate thing is
to remove the Hat as a sign of respect
if you go to different cultures and
other places around the world they also
have different types of Customs you go
to some places that you have to wear a
hat yeah you go into a jury synagogue so
you go to some Churches you take your
shoes off right right so different
places but the principle there is the
same showing reverence and respect thank
you Terry we got Brian listening in
Oklahoma Brian welcome to the program
I appreciate y'all's Ministry thank you
uh so my question is is I think I've
heard Pastor Doug refer to uh Moses as a
Christ type or a type of Christ yes and
I was wondering if you could explain
that for us
yeah there's probably many ways where
you could find typology how Moses is the
type of Christ first of all you don't
want to get it from me you listen to
what Paul says in First Corinthians
chapter 10 and he shows how the whole
Exodus experience is an allegory of
Salvation they were saved from the
bondage of the devil as we are saved
from the bondage of they were safe from
the Pharaoh as we're saved from the
devil Moses was born from slaves but he
never served as a slave and Jesus was
born of humans but he never sinned Moses
was what we call a mediator he would go
up the mountain and he God would speak
to him and he'd bring the message and
then they'd talk to Moses and he'd bring
the message to God and Jesus is our
mediator Moses was interceding for the
people he would lift up his hands and
they would win the battle he stretched
out his hands and Jesus stretched out
his hands
the word Moses means drawn from the
water Moses is actually an Egyptian word
they even had some pharaohs that were
called Tut Moses means drawn from the
water and Jesus you know the Bible tells
us in Revelation 17 the waters represent
multitudes of peoples and Nations Jesus
came from the people he came from the
slaves to save the slaves and Jesus came
from Humanity to save Humanity so you've
got uh amraham and djokobet had three
children
he had a trinity of children and they
were all prophets Mariam Aaron and Moses
all prophets he had the father Son and
Holy Spirit so you got all kinds of
illustrations and Moses had to die just
before they crossed over Jesus had to
die
for us to be able to cross over so I
could go on and on I have a book I wrote
on this matter of fact we're doing a new
study series called Shadows of light on
types of Christ in the Bible Moses is
one of those lessons but there's a book
you can just go to Amazon and type in
Shadows of light Doug Batchelor and
you'll see a book where I've got a whole
section on Moses
all right very good thank you next
holiday that we have is Kay listening in
Michigan okay welcome to the program
[Music]
what I knew about the clean and unclean
Foods
[Music]
my husband was listening to Str the
other night and a pastor on there said
he could not find in the Bible
where you could not eat duck
and I can't find it either now but all
my life I've been told no
what is your opinion well first of all
I'd say if you're in doubt do the safe
thing
so don't eat it but uh I do believe at
least in the King James version it
refers to swans as being unclean foul
and ducks and swans are in the same
category I can't remember the scientific
genus of how you say that but um you
know ducks are they're not a foraging
bird the clean birds were usually the
foraging birds that go around they pick
Karen and I were walking today and we
got surrounded by a herd of turkeys our
turkeys are heard
anyway and uh you know they go around
they they pack they eat seeds they eat
bugs and the Pheasant Quail they're all
the clean Birds the the partridges so
forth they were safe for sacrifice you
never seem sacrificing a duck or a swan
um so I would say they're in the unclean
category they usually muck around in the
lakes that they just they have a whole
different diet
anyway hope that helps a little bit
thank you thank you K we've got Mark
listening in Arkansas Mark welcome to
the program
Mark you're on how's it going yeah hello
hello good you're there
yeah it's actually Alaska oh it is okay
thank you that's right sorry
uh yeah I was really having a hard time
that a lot of times we keep charging our
acts and uh the influence of the evil
ones and my understanding was Jesus says
that we've been LED astray by our own
natural tendencies and so I went to
Jeremiah the prophet Jeremiah and he was
trying to tell us that the human heart
is deceitful above all things and
sometimes even desperately wicked and
that we uh fall into uh something like
foolish fears diver lust Envy enslaving
Pleasures malice envy and even vengeful
hatred so it seems to me that we are our
own enemy and Satan really ain't our
enemy it seems to me that we are maybe
I'm wrong but
if you're not connected to the vine
Jesus Christ then it's kind of hard to
produce good fruits and I just was
wondering what you thought about the
Prophet Jeremiah would tell us well
absolutely I I agree completely with the
prophet I agree with all the word but I
agree with Jeremiah that the Bible does
teach that an unconverted person the
human heart is selfish and desperately
wicked we all inherited these Fallen
Natures from Adam and Eve and originally
God created man to be motivated by love
but because of sin the compass was
broken the needle now points inward
instead of outward instead of pointing
away from ourselves and loving God and
loving others it points to love of self
as first
and
it then but when you're born again
through the Holy Spirit you get a new
nature
and you start learning through the
spirit to love and old things are passed
away all things have become new you have
new motives and new desires and doesn't
change all at once but many things can
change just through prayer and accepting
Christ where you get the Holy Spirit
you start thinking about love for God
and how much he gave and we love him
because he first loved us we love others
because we see how much he loves others
and yes the unconverted heart is evil
and desperately wicked the Bible says
all we like sheep have gone astray we've
turned each one to his own way the
selfish unconverted heart turns to its
own way but when we encounter Jesus and
we're born again we're made new
creatures things change and that's
called conversion and that's what we all
need to be praying for keep our eyes
fixed on Jesus we become like him
all right thank you Mark we got Megan
listening in Canada Megan welcome to the
program
hi thank you for having me thanks for
calling
um my question is about First
Corinthians uh Chapter 13 Verse one I've
always understood tongues to mean
languages
um but where it's
um talking about if I speak in the
tongues of men or of angels it made me
wonder
um what is speaking in tongues of angels
because I'm wondering if that's what
some people use to
um explain like sometimes they would say
they're speaking in tongues but it's not
something that can be translated
yeah I think you need to continue
reading well first of all I'm sure
Angels do have a language so I don't
doubt that for a moment because they do
communicate man has made a little lower
than the angels and we speak I'm sure
the Angels speak
um
but when Paul says though I speak with a
tongue of men and angels and have not
love I'm just a sounding brass or a
clinging symbol Paul was not saying that
he spoke with the tongue of Angels the
word though means even if because you
read on he says and though I have the
gift of Prophecy and understand all
Mysteries and have all knowledge well
clearly Paul did not understand all
Mysteries and have all knowledge
and though I have all Faith so I can
move mountains if I have not love it's
nothing
and then he says and though I give my
goods to feed the poor and though I give
my body to be burned Paul did not give
his body to be burned he didn't give
away all his Goods to feed the poor so
Paul is saying that even if you do all
these wonderful things
he didn't say he did them all so when he
says though I speak with the tongues of
men and angels Paul is says using an
illustration there he is not saying that
he or anyone in the world speaks with a
tongue of angels so does that make sense
Megan
yes it does okay thank you and do me a
favor there's a book we'll send you for
free and anyone who wants to understand
the gift of tongues a little better and
these very verses and just call and
we'll send it to you no strings attached
no one's going to knock on your door and
try and sell you any Hallelujah oil or
anything just call and ask for the book
understanding tongues we'll send you a
free copy and Pastor also give you the
number the number is
800-835-6747 and again you can just call
and ask we'll send it to you for free
it's called understanding tongues you'll
be blessed if you'd call and receive
that you can also dial pound 250. I
almost forgot about that and you can
just say Bible answers live and then ask
for the book called understanding
tongues and we can send it to you let's
say we got Robert listening in
Washington Robert walking the program
hey Pastor Ross and Pastor Bachelor hi
hi there I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I
could could be squeezed in yes sir and
your question
it's regarding uh a thing that I've
heard before people say
um that
once we dying
and go to heaven there's three levels of
levels of Heaven Celestial Celestial and
to terrestrial
um
and I've heard that it's supposed to be
in first Corinthians 15 I think 37 to 42
something like that yeah
um
but
that's the only place that that it's
referred to but I've always thought
there was just one there's only like we
either die or else we live forever
there's only two options I thought but
some people tell me that there's three
yeah the well I I don't think that First
Corinthians 15 verse uh 35 uh if we're
at 40 rather where it says there are
celestial bodies and terrestrial bodies
and the glory of the celestial is one
body Gloria the terrestrial is another
there's also the glory of the Sun and
the Moon the three Heavens that it
speaks about that Paul talks about it's
not talking about this the it's a
completely different teaching a
different um uh what do you call it's a
different application the three Heavens
they had the heaven that was the
atmosphere around the Earth
then they had the heaven that was the
starry bodies of space you can call them
the celestial then they had the heaven
that is the dwelling place of God that's
called the third heaven when Jesus comes
back and says I'll make a new Heaven A
New Earth the heavens and the Earth that
now exist are going to be burned up
meaning the atmosphere in the world you
know God separated the heavens from the
heaven there in Genesis the atmosphere
is going to burn up that's one heaven
when it says that uh you've got the
stars in heaven that's in the Moon and
the Sun and the stars and the heavenly
bodies that's the celestial bodies the
heaven where Paradise is the dwelling
place of God is the third heaven so I
wouldn't make a strong tie between First
Corinthians 15 40 and the three heavens
okay pastor Ross we got two minutes what
can we do in that time can we squeeze in
half a call absolutely we got let's see
d-rod listening from New Jersey d-rod
welcome to the program
good uh hello gentlemen how you doing uh
quick question about climate change
um this is in the Book of Matthew like
it was in the Davis
of Noah climate change what's the cause
of climate change to me it's sin all
right I just I just want to know that's
a good question it you know and I'm I'm
kind of rushing because we're against
the clock here but
um you know the Bible tells us that the
Earth waxes old like a garment and the
Earth is being crushed under a burden of
sin and I some no doubt man has had an
impact on the environment you know how
much the the warm and cold spells that
are in the Extremes in weather are
affected by you know man's construction
and CO2 as all kinds of debates about
that but there's no question man is
impacting the environment just in the
deforestation and stuff
I wish I could say more but we are out
of time hey friends don't go away
because we sign off our regular
listeners know that we've got people
listening on satellite radio they're on
a different clock than the land base
stations so we will be bidding them
farewell in just a moment but we're
going to stay by and answer some rapid
fire Bible questions that have come in
from those who email us questions some
people don't want to call they say I'd
just like to email it and listen off the
air what what's the address to do that
Pastor just Bal questions at
amazingfacts.org that's the email
address okay Bal questions at
amazingfacts.org you can send us
questions for the rest of you who are
listening on satellite stations around
the country and other parts of the world
God bless we'll look forward to studying
with you uh next time the rest stay by
we'll be back momentarily with rapid
fire Bible questions
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends welcome back to Bible
answers live we want to thank you for
your email questions that you've sent in
we're going to try and get through as
many of these questions as we can and as
we mentioned before the break if you
have an email question just simply send
it to
balquestions at amazingfacts.org
all right Pastor Doug first question
comes from Harry's asking what is the
sign mentioned in Matthew 24 that talks
about the sign of the son of man will
appear in heaven
yeah well some have wondered is that
like when Elijah said uh he saw a cloud
the side of a size of a man's hand
coming as a signal that the storm was
coming or is it where the Bible says the
heavens will depart as a scroll when it
is rolled together and all the stars
fall out of their place it's going to be
some Cosmic splitting sign that I think
everyone will recognize because Jesus
said it's like lightning going from one
end of the sky to the other so something
when you look up says whatever I will
see when he comes so something's
happening in the sky that's going to be
unmistakable okay another question on
behalf is the spirit referred to in
Genesis 1 verse 2 is that the Holy
Spirit and if so is it the spirit of the
father or the spirit of Jesus
well the holy spirit is not just talking
about the spirit of the Father the
spirit of Jesus the holy spirit is the
third person of the godhead
and he is equally connected with God the
father and God the son and yes it is the
same Spirit uh you find the Bible
beginning in Genesis it talks about
water and the spirit and then you go to
Revelation it says in the spirit and the
bride say come and whoever is a thirst
let him come and take the Waters of life
so you've got the Holy Spirit and the
waters in the beginning and at the end
of the Bible it's God the spirit okay we
got uh Tai asking from the UK of 144 000
symbolical literal
yeah good question
um you know I think people think the 144
000 are the only ones that are going to
be saved in the last days
on the day of Pentecost in the upper
room you have the 12 apostles that were
filled with the Holy Spirit plus there
was 120 and then a great multitude was
baptized through them in Revelation 7
when it talks about the hundred and
forty four thousand they're not the only
ones it says through their Ministry you
have a great multitude that comes out of
the final tribulation that no man can
number so
they're not the only ones say but it may
be a literal number just like the Twelve
Apostles was a literal number so
whenever you look at the hundred and
forty four thousand just think they're
like last day Apostles they're certainly
not the only ones saved but they got a
special work all right listening friends
now we're serious we're out of time we
hope that you'll let us know that you're
blessed by the programs connect with us
study the word
amazingfacts.org back next week
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]